are you both doing pretty good very good
so I want to start by saying
congratulations on the season it's
fantastic I want to ask you actually
some a little bit of some spoiler
questions which will run after release
okay so I loved the the ending of the
season which is the two of you it's not
about explosions it's not about some car
chase it's about two people sitting
across from one another having this you
know conversation we're basically both
sides have lost can you sort of talk
about filming that scene and you know
the culmination of the season thank you
the the scene was I mean it there was a
lot of build up to it you know what I
mean and some sort of debate on what the
scene was about but for me I didn't I
mean I was really excited to work with
Diego just because we had been working
for six months and I had seen him twice
you know so so part of me was what I'm
like finally working with the person
I've been chasing for so for me it was
really exciting I was really excited she
at the scene but then you know having
gotten into it and it seemed sort of out
of the direction it was going and the
way it was going it was I think it
turned out you know totally different
than the way that I thought it was going
to be in so much better than the way I
thought and it was sort of a throwback
to you I felt like me too Al Pacino
meeting Robert De Niro and heat in the
diner
you know and I mean it's just two guys
regular guys throwing away all their you
know what they do out the window and
just having a conversation with each
other it is a it is a nice metaphor you
know at the end is two victims of a
system of an issue that that is bigger
than them and just like looking at each
other's eyes and finding out nothing the
this is not this is not an ending of
anything it was just a beginning and it
connects with the present you know like
every every line over there it's talking
about where we live today here it's like
it reminds you that the
that for whatever is happening today
these had to happen you know 100 percent
the thing that I found so stewed is
Felix is basically laying out you you
[ __ ] up getting rid of me I could have
kept it all together and without me and
he just lays out how many problems can
happen there's no more organization
yeah and it I mean he seemed so he had
it you know he's just tell he's warning
you know about what the future can hold
for Mexico yeah I I would say for the
world you know it is because of what's
happening today it doesn't it's not
about Mexico is it's about a global
issue we have right so and and it
reminds you that at the end is the
structure is the political structure you
know what needs to change and an
impunity like putting him in jail is I
can't be called justice you know just
this is something bigger just this is a
full change of structure you know a
structural change that obviously didn't
happen then and hopefully can happen
soon one of the things that I watching
these watching people who have so much
money and so much power you wonder what
what would it take for them to actually
walk away Felix seemed like he was on
top of the world had money you know like
why is it that none of these people can
ever walk away from the life I think
they're not addicted to the money I
think they're addicted to the control
and the power and the money is just
something that comes with it you know
saw the interview was totally off topic
of a real estate mogul that was had so
much money and when is enough enough and
he said it's not about the money it's
about selling you know I mean it's about
making the deals and that's what they're
addicted to and I think that yeah these
characters are addicted to this power
that it gives them and also there is a
moment where you can't stop right
because I mean it's about surviving out
and you know once you become that
important then you're that important and
and this fits so many people around you
know it's not just it's not a one-man
business
you know it's a country it's it's a
party's that the government is the whole
thing so you become indispensable then
it's the worst that can happen to you I
guess for I'm curious for fans of narcos
and narcos Mexico do you think there's
anything that would surprise people to
learn about the actual making of the
show I feel like it's making it's like
making an 80 million dollar independent
movie okay you know you can just a lot
of freedom you know but you just you
have a lot of money at your disposal but
but yet the sort of the way that we
shoot down there and make the movie is
very very loose yeah it is it is very
Mexican and that from that perspective
right it's that we should the way we
should movies and it's mostly a Mexican
crew and and it has that feeling of like
yeah you can always go further and we're
always trying more and more and wanting
to see more and and it's it's it's an
interesting time also because most of
the crew working there we grew up in
that Mexico
we know that Mexico we're talking about
you know so so there's there's this love
for specificity that that I think you
see you see on the frame when you think
back on the making of season 2 is there
a sequence or a day that will always
stand the test of time you know whether
it be an action set piece whether it be
an dialogue scene these are certain
things that really pop out I mean
nobody crazy they's it's a tease but it
was just so much so much fun I'll tell
you one like we recreated meaning of the
election in the in 88
you know demo card analysis is in the
fields talking to a bunch of people
there and we were walking through the
people with the camera behind Felix and
he's getting to the podium and finding
the candidate there and I remember that
election I remember the that those days
I remember those meetings and and he was
he was quite interesting to leave it
because I was suddenly back in time in
my country in a very important moment
and I don't know it was it was I I
grabbed I even grabbed like an image of
the candidate and took it home and put
it there it's it's the exact same like
it replicates perfectly what was
happening you know anything for you
honey
it just pops out I mean just the
locations that we you know went to it's
not like you can where we're shooting
the locations it's not something that's
on the tourist guide so you get to see
all these different parts of Mexico that
are just I mean I couldn't I couldn't
identify one specific moment because
every day was you know going to a new
location who set new area I was just
constantly in awe of the country and how
beautiful was and and everything set
pieces sure my last thing for you real
quick when you started the season how
much did you know about the full arc and
where it was ultimately going to end up
and how much were you sort of finding
out script by script I think like in
general the general arc I I knew from
the beginning from the beginning of
season 1 and we were already talking
about season 2 Eric has the whole series
in his head
and you just have to sit down for lunch
with him and you get it I I knew I knew
what was gonna happen but it's it's
interesting because also there's new
characters coming in so you don't know
how that's gonna work and and these
specifics obviously but uh but I had a
chance to see the whole thing which was
very useful you know in order to make
the choices that I needed to be doing in
the process it's a Merricks very
detailed very thorough sort of gave me
the lay of the whole season of where
it's going and obviously when he tells
me it's like eight nine or rough
episodes eight nine ten
you know but he generally knows exactly
where it's going and where and as far as
seeing it in script format and like the
story and stuff